so we're going to start with uh the
basics they're just called mills so as
you guys saw in my routine i was doing
all this stuff
you take the club between both fingers
and you flip it to the back
oop yeah and make sure so in gymnastics
your arm
always has to be straight you're going
to hit yourself so we don't want that
yeah yes so just straight
like that yeah yeah like that cardi b is
learning rhythmic gymnastics in the
newest episode of cardi tries
out now on messenger there's some big
big things on the way
big things it might look easy at home
but this right here is like
like a plunge like this like a plunger
like if you're like moving a plunger
oh yes honey at one point cardi
incorporates a ball
into her moves feel the ball yeah
but when it came to using a hula hoop
things proved
more difficult
you know what i've never been a person
that hula hoop and i could tell you now
i never will and mind you cardi is doing
all of this while pregnant with her
second child
and at the end of all of cardi's lessons
she and pal amanda seals put on a show
for the crowd
[Music]
circles all right all right clearly
their teacher
gymnast stasia generalova was impressed
ever since i was a little girl my my
teachers always told me that i was going
to be somebody out or whatever
cardi is certainly somebody obviously
she's a superstar
a mama with a beautiful family and now
she can add
gymnast to that resume
as your career gets bigger and bigger
how are you feeling about stardom is it
everything that you
thought it was gonna be is it harder
better it's
definitely harder like the more money
the more problems the more people
um that that things they know you
and their opinions it just gets harder
people don't understand some people
don't understand the
the struggle some people don't
understand the work that i put in so
they will just always try to think that
it came easy for me
how are you balancing everything and are
you experiencing that mom guilt a little
bit
i do experience that mom guilt you know
she's like oh my gosh all that traveling
and i know her sleeping schedule is
getting a little messed up
and i know every single time that she
get on an airplane
it's all good and to the landing she
starts crying and i just be feeling so
sad because it's like i know the pain
you know when your ears pop
i just be so sad and like sometimes i
wake up in the morning and like
she's in my bed and i just want to
cuddle with this totally
i seen you do it no okay cardinal okay
you know what i just
can we move